hey guys so i'm here with warren  thompson from cosmic wonder  eric voss you might have heard of him  before he's got a growing channel right  now  but guys we just got out of eternals  and what i really want to say is  i really love john humphrey what do you  guys think of joe john is this great guy  great great guy  the hair  so beautiful he's such a beautiful man  you know it's like whenever we're the  three of us are talking every friday  all we do is talk about john and how  great of a guy don't ever tell him that  we do don't tell him cause he'll go  regular i'll go right to his head we  don't want to spoil him we don't want to  spoil the guy because john is like the  most amazing guy in the world  but guys eternals okay quick thoughts